أهلاً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية. اسمي John Watrous وأنا المدير التقني للتعليم في IBM
Quantum. هذا هو الدرس الثاني عشر في السلسلة وهو الدرس الأخير في الوحدة الثالثة التي تتناول الصياغة العامة
للمعلومات الكمية. هذا الدرس يتمحور حول مفهوم أساسي في المعلومات الكمية وهو مفهوم
تنقية الحالة الكمية. تنقية حالة كمية ممثلة بمصفوفة كثافة ما هي
حالة نقية لنظام مركب أكبر تتركنا مع الحالة الأصلية عندما يُتخلص من بقية النظام المركب
أو يُؤخذ أثره الجزئي. كل مصفوفة كثافة لها تنقية ويمكننا تعلم الكثير
عن الحالات الكمية وعن المعلومات الكمية بشكل عام من خلال دراسة التنقيات. على المستوى الحدسي
متجهات الحالة الكمية التي تمثل حالات نقية هي كائنات رياضية أبسط من مصفوفات الكثافة. وبالتفكير في
تنقيات الحالات نستطيع رؤية حالات كمية عشوائية لأنظمة كأجزاء من شيء أكبر لكن
أبسط. سنتحدث أيضاً عن الإخلاص بين حالتين كميتين وهو قيمة تحدد كمياً
تشابههما أو تداخلهما وغالباً ما يُستخدم كطريقة لقياس جودة حالة معينة مقارنة
بحالة مثالية ما. بشكل خاص سنناقش تعريف الإخلاص مع بعض خصائصه الأساسية وسنرى
كيف يرتبط الإخلاص بالتنقيات. هذه نظرة عامة على الدرس. سنبدأ بالتنقيات بما في ذلك
التعريف وبرهان بسيط على وجودها يخبرنا كيف نجد واحدة إذا احتجنا. ثم سنناقش شيئاً يُعرف
بتحليل Schmidt لمتجه حالة كمية لنظامين وسنرى كيف تتعلق تحليلات Schmidt
بالتنقيات. ثم سنناقش علاقة بالغة الأهمية بين أي تنقيتين لنفس الحالة والتي تُعرف بالتكافؤ الوحدوي
للتنقيات. وأخيراً سنستعرض بعض الأمثلة. ثم ننتقل إلى الإخلاص
بما في ذلك تعريفه وبعض خصائصه الأساسية. سنتحدث عن مبرهنة القياس اللطيف وهي حقيقة مفيدة
جداً تربط الإخلاص بالقياسات. وأخيراً لنختم الدرس سننتقل إلى نظرية Uhlmann التي
تؤسس علاقة أساسية بين الإخلاص والتنقيات. لنبدأ بتعريف
التنقية. تنقية حالة نفترض أنها ممثلة بمصفوفة
كثافة هي حالة نقية لنظام مركب أكبر تترك لنا الحالة الأصلية التي بدأنا بها عندما يُؤخذ الأثر
الجزئي لبقية النظام المركب. يمكننا التعبير عن هذا بدقة أكبر بالمصطلحات الرياضية
كالتالي. إذا كان لدينا نظام X في حالة ما rho أي أن rho مصفوفة كثافة تمثل حالة X
و s متجه حالة كمية لزوج من الأنظمة XY بحيث أن أخذ الأثر الجزئي على Y من الحالة النقية ket psi bra psi
يتركنا مع rho فعندئذ نقول إن s تنقية لـ rho. بالطبع الأسماء لا تهم يمكننا
تسمية أنظمتنا وحالاتنا كما نشاء وترتيب الأنظمة أيضاً لا يهم. مثلاً
لو كان النظام Y على اليسار بدلاً من اليمين لكن كل شيء آخر نفسه لكنا لا نزال نشير إلى psi كتنقية لـ rho. لكننا
سنلتزم بهذا الإعداد لبقية الدرس من أجل البساطة. وأول شيء نقوله عن
التعريف هو أن التنقيات موجودة دائماً لكل مصفوفة كثافة rho. ولنكون أدق كل مصفوفة
كثافة rho لها تنقية كما يصف التعريف بشرط أن يكون النظام Y بحجم X على الأقل أي
أن Y لديه على الأقل نفس عدد الحالات الكلاسيكية التي لدى X. مفهوم التنقية و
حقيقة أن التنقيات موجودة دائماً يتبين أنه بالغ الأهمية وهو أيضاً جزء مما يجعل المعلومات الكمية جميلة وآمل أن
أتمكن من إقناعكم بذلك بحلول نهاية الدرس. الآن لنبرهن أن كل مصفوفة كثافة لها تنقية و
في هذه العملية سنرى كيف يمكننا الحصول على تنقية عندما نحتاج واحدة. تماماً كما كان في التعريف
لنفترض أن X نظام و rho مصفوفة كثافة تمثل حالة
X. الآن ننظر في أي تعبير لـ rho كتركيب محدب من حالات نقية كما كتبنا على الشاشة. بالكلمات
لاختيار ما لعدد صحيح موجب n لدينا متجه احتمالي p0 إلى pN ناقص واحد بالإضافة إلى متجهات حالة
كمية phi 0 إلى phi N ناقص واحد وبحساب متوسط الحالات النقية المقابلة موزونة بالاحتمالات
نحصل على rho. مثلاً يمكننا استخدام النظرية الطيفية للحصول على تعبير لـ rho بهذا الشكل. وإذا فعلنا ذلك
يمكننا أخذ n ليكون عدد الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ X. في الحقيقة يمكننا أخذ n ليكون رتبة rho التي تساوي
عدد القيم الذاتية غير الصفرية لـ rho مع حساب كل واحدة عدداً من المرات يساوي تعدديتها و
هذا لا يتجاوز أبداً عدد الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ X لكنه قد يكون أصغر. من ناحية أخرى هذا لا يحتاج
أن يكون تحليلاً طيفياً لـ rho ولا نحتاج لهذه المتجهات أن تكون متعامدة. مثلاً أي تعبير لـ rho بهذا الشكل
مقبول. وهنا تنقية لـ rho: المجموع يمتد على نفس القيم كما
في تعبيرنا لـ rho وداخل المجموع نأخذ الجذور التربيعية للاحتمالات مضروبة في phi a الجداء التنسوري
مع ket a. هنا بالمناسبة نفترض أن 0 إلى n ناقص واحد حالات كلاسيكية للنظام الثاني Y فمن
المنطقي أن s متجه حالة كمية للزوج XY كما في التعريف. ليس مهماً فعلاً
هنا أننا نستخدم حالات الأساس المعياري لـ Y في هذا التعبير. يمكنك استبدال أي مجموعة متعامدة معيارية من
الحالات بدلاً من ket 0 إلى ket n ناقص واحد إذا أردت. والآن يمكننا التحقق من أن هذه فعلاً
تنقية بحساب الأثر الجزئي على Y. هنا تعبير للحالة التي نحصل عليها بأخذ الأثر الجزئي.
أثر ket a bra b هو إما واحد أو صفر حسب ما إذا كان a يساوي b أم لا وبالتالي يتبسط التعبير
إلى تعبيرنا الأصلي لـ rho. وهذا ببساطة كل شيء. فمن السهل جداً الحصول على
تنقية طالما لدينا حالات كلاسيكية كافية لـ Y أو بديلاً مجموعة متعامدة معيارية كبيرة بما يكفي لاستخدامها
بدلاً من حالات الأساس المعياري ket 0 إلى ket n ناقص واحد. وبالمناسبة إذا كان عدد
الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ Y أصغر من رتبة rho فلن تكون هناك تنقية وسأترك لكم التفكير
في ذلك إذا أردتم. هنا مثال. لننظر في
مصفوفة الكثافة التي رأيناها عدة مرات في درس مصفوفات الكثافة. هنا لدينا تعبير لهذه
المصفوفة كتركيب محدب من حالات نقية. ليس تحليلاً طيفياً لكننا لا
نهتم. وبجهد شبه معدوم يمكننا كتابة تنقية للحالة باتباع
الوصفة. هذه ليست التنقية الوحيدة لهذه المصفوفة. التنقيات ليست فريدة لكن هذا مقبول.
التعريف لا يقول شيئاً عن التفرد. وفي الحقيقة هناك علاقة مثيرة جداً بين التنقيات المختلفة لنفس الحالة لكننا
سنناقش ذلك لاحقاً في الدرس. بعد ذلك سننظر في تحليلات Schmidt وهي تعبيرات لمتجهات حالة كمية
ثنائية الأجزاء بشكل معين سأصفه بعد قليل. سُميت على اسم Erhard
Schmidt نفس Schmidt المعروف بإجراء Gram-Schmidt للتعامد. لكن في حالة تحليلات Schmidt ربما لا يجب
أن تُنسب إلى Schmidt. فهي في الواقع مكافئة رياضياً لشيء يُسمى تحليل القيمة المفردة للمصفوفات وهو شيء
أُعيد اكتشافه عدة مرات. لكن هذا يحدث أحياناً. على كل حال هذا ما نعنيه
عندما نشير إلى تحليل Schmidt. لأي اختيار عشوائي لمتجه حالة كمية s لزوج من
الأنظمة XY من الممكن دائماً كتابة s بشكل خاص. ذلك الشكل هو كما
لدينا هنا على الشاشة حيث R عدد صحيح موجب و p0 إلى pR ناقص واحد أعداد حقيقية موجبة
تشكل معاً متجه احتمالي و x0 إلى xR ناقص واحد متجهات وحدة تتوافق مع النظام X و y0
إلى yR ناقص واحد متجهات وحدة تتوافق مع النظام Y. الآن قد لا يبدو هذا مميزاً
بشكل خاص حتى أخبركم أن كلتا المجموعتين x0 إلى xR ناقص واحد و y0 إلى yR ناقص واحد يجب أن تكونا
متعامدتين معياريتين. فلماذا هذا مميز؟ حسناً إذا اخترنا أي أساس لأحد الأساسين لنقل
متجهات X المقابلة للنظام X فيمكننا دائماً التعبير عن s بهذا الشكل وذلك سيجبرنا على
اختيار متجهات Y بطريقة معينة. في الحقيقة نفعل هذا بشكل روتيني كما نفعل مع الأساس المعياري عندما
نهيئ أنفسنا لتحليل قياس الأساس المعياري. لكن بشكل عام حتى لو اخترنا أساساً متعامداً معيارياً لمتجهات
X فإن متجهات Y التي نحصل عليها لن تكون بالضرورة متعامدة معيارية. وبالمثل إذا اخترت
أساساً متعامداً معيارياً لمتجهات Y وحاولت التعبير عن s بهذا الشكل مرة أخرى يمكنك ذلك لكن متجهات X لن تكون
بالضرورة متعامدة معيارية. وأخيراً لو اخترت متجهات متعامدة معيارية لكلا النظامين
وحاولت التعبير عن s بشكل كهذا فلن ينجح بالضرورة لأنك قد تحتاج بعض الحدود المتقاطعة. لكن هناك فهرس واحد
فقط في هذا المجموع وهو a فالشكل مميز. لكنه ممكن دائماً
لكتابة متجه وحدة معطى s بهذا الشكل. وإليك كيفية القيام بذلك: أولاً احسب تحليلاً طيفياً
للحالة المختزلة لأي من النظامين لا يهم أيهما. لكن من أجل وصف الطريقة لننظر في الحالة المختزلة
لـ X فنحن نأخذ الأثر الجزئي على Y. هذا يعني أن p0 إلى pR ناقص واحد هي القيم
الذاتية لهذه الحالة المختزلة rho و x0 إلى xR ناقص واحد متجهات ذاتية وحدوية تقابل هذه القيم الذاتية و
بالمناسبة المفهوم هنا هو أننا نتجاهل الحدود التي قيمها الذاتية صفر لأن تلك الحدود لا تساهم بشيء في
المجموع. أي أن p0 إلى pR ناقص واحد كلها أعداد حقيقية موجبة و R هو عدد القيم الذاتية غير
الصفرية مع حساب التعدديات وهو يساوي رتبة rho. فهذا يعطينا p0 إلى pR
ناقص واحد بالإضافة إلى x0 إلى xR ناقص واحد. وكل ما تبقى هو إيجاد المتجهات y0 إلى yR ناقص
واحد. هناك اختيار واحد فقط يمكن أن ينجح فهذه المتجهات محددة بشكل وحيد عند هذه النقطة ويمكن
إيجادها بسهولة باستخدام الصيغة البسيطة الموضحة على الشاشة. والمذهل هنا هو أننا
إذا عرّفنا هذه المتجهات بهذه الطريقة فإنها مضمونة أن تكون متعامدة معيارية. وهذا يعطينا تحليل Schmidt. لن أبرهن ذلك في هذا
الفيديو لكنه ليس صعباً جداً ويمكنك الرجوع للمادة المكتوبة للدرس إذا كنت مهتماً. تفقد
وصف الفيديو للرابط كالعادة. كمثال لننظر في متجه
الحالة الكمية هذا الذي حصلنا عليه كتنقية لمثال مصفوفة الكثافة الذي نعود إليه
باستمرار. ليس تحليل Schmidt لأن حالتي الصفر و plus ليستا متعامدتين معيارياً. لكن يمكننا إيجاد واحد
باستخدام الإجراء الذي وصفته للتو. الخطوة الأولى هي حساب تحليل طيفي للحالة
المختزلة لـ X وهي نفس مثال مصفوفة الكثافة. وهنا تحليل طيفي لها رأيناه
في الدرس التاسع. فنختار p0 و p1 و x0 و x1 كما هو
موضح على الشاشة. p0 و p1 هما القيمتان الذاتيتان لـ rho و x0 و x1 هما
متجهان ذاتيان وحدويان مقابلان. ويبقى حساب y0 و y1 وإذا فعلنا ذلك نحصل على ket plus
لـ y0 و سالب واحد ضرب ket minus لـ y1. هذا ليس فورياً عليك فعلاً
إجراء الحساب لتراه لكن هذا ما نحصل عليه. وكما هو متوقع هذان المتجهان متعامدان معيارياً كما
سيكونان دائماً إذا أجريت الحسابات بشكل صحيح. وهذا يعطينا تحليل
Schmidt. تحليلات Schmidt مفيدة جداً في مواقف كثيرة وسنرى قريباً ما تخبرنا به
عن التنقيات. التنقيات ليست فريدة. حالة كمية معينة ممثلة
بمصفوفة كثافة ستكون لها في الحقيقة عدد لا نهائي من التنقيات. لكن هناك علاقة وثيقة
تنطبق دائماً بين أي تنقيتين لنفس الحالة وتُسمى أحياناً التكافؤ الوحدوي
للتنقيات. وإليك كيف يعمل: لتكن rho مصفوفة كثافة
تمثل حالة كمية لنظام X ولنفترض أن لدينا أي تنقيتين لتلك الحالة هما
حالتان نقيتان لنفس النظام المركب. فمن أجل الوضوح لنفترض أن psi و phi
متجها حالة كمية لزوج من الأنظمة XY وكلاهما يعطينا rho عند أخذ الأثر الجزئي على النظام Y.
ما يقوله التكافؤ الوحدوي للتنقيات هو أنه لا بد من وجود عملية وحدوية U تعمل فقط على
النظام Y تحوّل psi إلى phi. بعبارة أخرى رغم أن هذه
تنقيات عشوائية لـ rho ولا نفترض شيئاً عنها سوى أن كلتيهما تنقيان rho وأنهما
حالتان لنفس النظام المركب XY فلا بد أن تكونا متكافئتين بمعنى ما حتى عملية وحدوية على Y
وحده. سنرى بعض الأمثلة التي توضح لماذا هذا مثير للاهتمام وما تداعياته. لكن أولاً لنرَ
لماذا هو صحيح. لنبدأ بتحليل طيفي لـ rho وهي
مصفوفة الكثافة التي كلتا psi و phi تنقيانها. وتماماً كما فعلنا عند مناقشة تحليل Schmidt سنفترض
أننا تخلصنا من كل الحدود المقابلة لقيم ذاتية صفرية. فـ p0 إلى pR ناقص واحد
كلها أعداد حقيقية موجبة و x0 إلى xR ناقص واحد متجهات ذاتية متعامدة معيارية لـ rho و R هو
رتبة rho. وبالمناسبة كملاحظة جانبية لاحظ كم مرة نلجأ للنظرية الطيفية عند هذه النقطة.
إنها أداة مفيدة بشكل لا يُصدق وفي الحقيقة سنكون ضائعين بدونها. على كل حال الآن بعد أن لدينا تحليلاً طيفياً
لـ rho يمكننا حساب تحليلات Schmidt لمتجهينا تماماً كما فعلنا سابقاً وستكون
متطابقة تقريباً. المعاملات ومتجهات X هي نفسها لأنها تأتي من التحليل الطيفي للحالة المختزلة التي
هي نفسها لكلا المتجهين. الفرق الوحيد هو أننا قد نحصل على متجهات مختلفة للنظام الثاني. للمتجه
الأول وهو psi سنحصل على مجموعة متجهات y0 إلى yR ناقص واحد وللمتجه الثاني وهو phi سنحصل
على مجموعة مختلفة محتملة يمكننا تسميتها z0 إلى zR ناقص واحد. فلدينا الآن تحليلات Schmidt
لمتجهينا وهي تبدو متشابهة جداً إلا أن متجهات النظام الثاني قد تكون مختلفة. لكن هذه
تحليلات Schmidt فهاتان المجموعتان كلتاهما متعامدتان معيارياً ولذلك يمكننا ببساطة اختيار
مصفوفة وحدوية U ترسل ya إلى za لكل a. يمكنك فعل ذلك دائماً فالعمليات
الوحدوية مكافئة في الحقيقة لتطبيقات خطية تحوّل أساساً متعامداً معيارياً إلى آخر. وإذا
كانت هاتان المجموعتان لا تولدان الفضاء الكامل المقابل لـ Y يمكننا دائماً توسيعهما كلتيهما إلى أساسين
متعامدين معياريين باستخدام إجراء Gram-Schmidt للتعامد بالمصادفة. وهكذا يُبرهن التكافؤ الوحدوي
للتنقيات. في الدرس الرابع من السلسلة ناقشنا بروتوكول الترميز فائق الكثافة
الذي يسمح للمرسل بنقل بتين كلاسيكيتين إلى المستقبل بإرسال qubit واحد بتكلفة ebit واحد من
التشابك المشترك. فأنا أفترض أنكم على دراية بذلك البروتوكول. والهدف من هذا المثال هو شرح
باختصار كيف يرتبط بالتكافؤ الوحدوي للتنقيات. تذكروا أن طريقة عمل
البروتوكول هي أن Alice و Bob يتشاركان ebit أو بعبارة أخرى حالة Bell phi plus. تختار Alice تحويل تلك
الحالة إلى أي من حالات Bell الأربع حسب البتين اللتين تريد إرسالهما ثم ترسل
الـ qubit الخاص بها إلى Bob وهو يقيس ليرى أي حالة Bell لديه. لاحظ أن حالات Bell الأربع جميعها
تعطينا نفس الحالة المختزلة لـ qubit الخاص بـ Bob وهي الحالة المختلطة تماماً. وفي الحقيقة هذا كافٍ بالفعل
للاستنتاج أن الترميز فائق الكثافة ممكن. جميع حالات Bell الأربع تنقي الحالة المختلطة تماماً فبالتكافؤ
الوحدوي للتنقيات نعلم أنه لا بد أن يكون ممكناً لـ Alice تحويل حالة Bell phi plus إلى
أي من الأخريات بتطبيق عملية وحدوية على الـ qubit الخاص بها. بالطبع ليس من الصعب إيجاد عمليات وحدوية تعمل
فعلاً وهي بسيطة جداً. لكن من المثير مع ذلك أننا نستطيع الوصول إلى استنتاج أن هذا
ممكن بدون حتى التفكير في العمليات الوحدوية نفسها. وعلاوة على ذلك يمكننا أن نستنتج
أن تعميمات الترميز فائق الكثافة لأنظمة أكبر ممكنة بشرط أن يكون لدينا طريقة لتعميم حالات Bell لأنظمة
أكبر بحيث تعطي جميعها الحالة المختلطة تماماً كحالة مختزلة لـ Bob. وهناك فعلاً طرق معروفة مختلفة
لذلك. سياق مختلف يكون للتكافؤ الوحدوي للتنقيات تداعيات فيه هو التشفير
الكمي. وإحدى أهم تداعياته هي أنه يستبعد وجود بروتوكول كمي آمن بشكل غير مشروط لبدائية
تشفيرية تُعرف بالتزام البت. فما هو التزام البت؟ التزام البت هو مثال
على بدائية تشفيرية ونعني بذلك مهمة أو إجراء منخفض المستوى يوفر بعض الوظائف الأساسية التي
يمكن استخدامها كلبنة بناء لعمل أشياء أكثر إثارة مثل إنشاء مخططات التوقيع الرقمي أو بناء
بروتوكولات المعرفة الصفرية مثلاً. في حالة التزام البت الوظيفة الأساسية هي أن
أحد اللاعبين Alice تستطيع الالتزام بقيمة ثنائية من اختيارها لدى لاعب ثانٍ Bob لكن اختيارها يبقى مخفياً
حتى تختار الكشف عنه. نطلب خاصيتين محددتين من بروتوكول ينفذ التزام
البت. يجب أن يكون ملزِماً بمعنى أن Alice لا تستطيع تغيير رأيها بعد أن تلتزم ببت. ويجب
أن يكون مخفياً بمعنى أن Bob لا يستطيع تحديد بت Alice حتى تختار الكشف
عنه. فسيكون جميلاً جداً أن نتمكن من تنفيذ هذه البدائية باستخدام المعلومات الكمية لأنها
بدائية مفيدة. لكن بدون افتراضات إضافية يتبين أنه مستحيل فعلها بشكل مثالي بالمعلومات الكمية أو حتى قريباً
من المثالي. والتكافؤ الوحدوي للتنقيات يكشف ذلك. الفكرة على مستوى عالٍ جداً هي
أنه لو كان هناك بروتوكول كمي لالتزام البت لكان لا بد من وجود نسخة منقاة من ذلك البروتوكول حيث يمكننا تخيل أن
Alice لديها نظام A و Bob لديه نظام B وبعد إجراء الالتزام لكن قبل أن تكشف Alice يكون الزوج AB في
إحدى حالتين نقيتين psi صفر أو psi واحد حسب البت الذي تلتزم به Alice.
إذا كان البروتوكول مخفياً تماماً فلا بد أن Bob لا يستطيع التفريق بين
الالتزامين فحالته المختزلة يجب أن تكون نفسها للاحتمالين. لكن هذا يعني بالتكافؤ
الوحدوي للتنقيات أن Alice تستطيع تحويل أي منهما إلى الآخر بتطبيق عملية وحدوية
على A وحده. فالبروتوكول فشل تماماً في أن يكون ملزِماً. هناك تفاصيل
أخفيتها لكن جوهر الأمر هو أن التكافؤ الوحدوي للتنقيات يخبرنا أن هذه البدائية ليست شيئاً
يمكننا تنفيذه بشكل موثوق باستخدام المعلومات الكمية بدون افتراضات إضافية من نوع
ما. المثال الأخير لتداعيات التكافؤ الوحدوي للتنقيات هو نظرية تُعرف بنظرية
Hughston-Jozsa-Wootters أو نظرية HJW اختصاراً. لنبدأ بعبارة
النظرية نفسها وهذه نسخة مبسطة قليلاً لتجنب بعض التقنيات حتى نركز على الأفكار
الرئيسية. لنفترض أن X و Y نظامان و phi أي متجه حالة كمية يمثل حالة نقية للزوج
XY. والآن لنفترض أننا نفكر في الحالة المختزلة للنظام X وحده ونأتي بأي طريقة نختارها
للتعبير عن هذه الحالة المختزلة كتركيب محدب من حالات نقية كما هو موضح على الشاشة.
فمثلاً العدد N الكبير في هذا التعبير وهو عدد الحالات النقية التي نحسب متوسطها يمكن أن يكون
كبيراً جداً وربما أكبر بكثير من بُعد الفضاء المقابل لـ X أو لـ Y لهذا
الشأن. وما تخبرنا به النظرية هو أنه لا بد من وجود قياس على النظام Y بعدد N من النتائج بحيث
يحدث التالي عند قياس النظام Y. أولاً كل نتيجة قياس
تظهر باحتمال يساوي تماماً الاحتمال المقابل في تعبيرنا عن الحالة المختزلة لـ X
كتركيب محدب من حالات نقية. وثانياً بشرط الحصول على نتيجة قياس معينة فإن
حالة X تصبح الحالة النقية المقابلة من التركيب المحدب. فلماذا هذا
مثير للاهتمام؟ يعني أنه لأي طريقة نختارها للتفكير في الحالة المختزلة لـ X كتركيب
محدب من حالات نقية هناك قياس ما لـ Y يجعل هذه الطريقة في التفكير عن الحالة المختزلة لـ X
واقعاً. والمذهل هو أن هذا ممكن حتى عندما تُختار الحالة phi أولاً والتركيب
المحدب يُختار لاحقاً. طالما أنه تعبير عن الحالة المختزلة لـ X سيكون هناك
قياس لـ Y يعمل تماماً هكذا. فلنرَ كيف يمكننا إثبات
هذا. نبدأ بتعبيرين مختلفين للحالة المختزلة لـ X التي سنسميها rho
للراحة. ثم نُدخل نظاماً جديداً Z حالاته الكلاسيكية هي نتائج القياس الممكنة أو
ما يكافئ فهارس التركيب المحدب. والآن يمكننا ملاحظة أن متجهي الحالة الكمية التاليين
gamma 0 و gamma 1 وهما متجها حالة للنظام المركب XYZ كلاهما
تنقيتان لـ rho. وللتوضيح عندما نفكر في هذين المتجهين كتنقيتين لـ rho نحن
نفكر في النظامين Y و Z معاً كنظام مركب واحد يُؤخذ أثره الجزئي ليتركنا مع
rho. المتجه الأول gamma 0 هو أساساً نفس الحالة النقية الأصلية phi إلا أننا
نهيئ النظام الجديد Z في حالة الصفر. واضح أنه إذا أخذنا الأثر الجزئي على Y و Z سنبقى مع rho فـ gamma
0 تنقية لـ rho. المتجه الثاني gamma 1 هو أساساً المتجه الذي نحصل عليه بتنقية
rho بناءً على التركيب المحدب تماماً كما وصفت سابقاً في الدرس. هذه المرة النظام Y
مهيأ وأنا أفترض للبساطة أن الصفر حالة كلاسيكية لـ Y. لكن يمكنك استبدال أي
حالة أساس معياري أو في الحقيقة أي حالة نقية لـ Y في هذا التعبير ولن يُحدث أي فرق. في كل الأحوال أخذ الأثر الجزئي على Y و
Z مرة أخرى يتركنا مع rho. فالخلاصة هي أن كلتيهما تنقيتان لـ rho ولذلك بالتكافؤ
الوحدوي للتنقيات هناك عملية وحدوية U على الزوج YZ تحوّل gamma 0 إلى
gamma 1. وهذا كل ما نحتاجه للتوصل إلى وصف لقياس يفعل ما تقوله
النظرية. طريقة بسيطة لوصفه هي بمخطط circuit كما هو موضح هنا على الشاشة. بالكلمات نبدأ
بالحالة phi ونُدخل Z مهيأً في حالة الصفر ونُجري U ثم نقيس النظام العلوي وهو Z بقياس
أساس معياري. فعلياً ما يفعله هذا هو تحويل phi إلى gamma 1 و
بمجرد النظر لوصف gamma 1 يمكننا رؤية أن هذا يفعل ما تقوله النظرية وهو أننا نحصل
على كل نتيجة a باحتمال pA وبشرط الحصول على a يبقى النظام X في الحالة psi
a. وللتوضيح القياس نفسه الذي تؤكد النظرية وجوده يُنفذ بكل
ما داخل المستطيل المنقط في الشكل. وإذا أردتم معرفة كيف يمكن وصف
القياس كمجموعة من المصفوفات فهنا تعبير لها. لن أشرح هذا الجزء وليس
مهماً حقاً لهذا المثال لكن هذا تعبير لمصفوفات القياس في حال كنتم
مهتمين. بعد ذلك سنناقش الإخلاص وهو مقياس لمدى تشابه حالتين كميتين أو بديلاً
مقدار تداخلهما. سنبدأ بالتعريف الذي قد يبدو غامضاً قليلاً
للوهلة الأولى لكننا سنفككه وبنهاية النقاش آمل أن أكون قد أقنعتكم بأنها
في الحقيقة دالة أجمل بكثير مما قد تبدو للوهلة الأولى. وإليكم
التعريف: الإخلاص بين مصفوفتي كثافة rho و sigma يساوي أثر الجذر التربيعي لـ
الجذر التربيعي لـ rho ضرب sigma ضرب الجذر التربيعي لـ rho. سنتحدث عن
ذلك. أولاً لنحاول فهم التعريف نفسه. لدينا ثلاثة جذور تربيعية و
كلها تشير إلى الجذر التربيعي لمصفوفة شبه موجبة المحددة والذي كما ناقشنا في الدرس السابق هو
المصفوفة الوحيدة شبه الموجبة المحددة التي تربيعها يعطينا أي مصفوفة نأخذ جذرها التربيعي. لأن
rho مصفوفة كثافة فلا بد أن تكون شبه موجبة المحددة فيمكننا أخذ جذرها. وإذا فكرنا في الجذر التربيعي لـ rho ضرب
sigma ضرب الجذر التربيعي لـ rho للحظة نرى أنها أيضاً شبه موجبة المحددة. وبشكل خاص يمكننا كتابتها
كـ M المرافقة ضرب M حيث M هي الجذر التربيعي لـ sigma ضرب الجذر التربيعي لـ rho وبالتالي يمكننا أخذ الجذر
التربيعي لها. بشكل خاص يمكننا حساب تحليل طيفي لجذر
rho ضرب sigma ضرب جذر rho ثم لأخذ الجذر التربيعي نحتاج فقط لأخذ الجذور التربيعية للقيم
الذاتية وترك المتجهات الذاتية كما هي. وأخيراً نأخذ أثر
هذه المصفوفة. ولأن الأثر يساوي مجموع القيم الذاتية نحصل على التعبير الموجود
هنا. فهذا شيء ربما لا تريد حسابه يدوياً بشكل عام. وهذا الشرح قد لا
يقدم الكثير من البصيرة عن الإخلاص أو لماذا نهتم به لكن آمل أنه يوضح المعنى التقني
للصيغة. بالمناسبة كملاحظة جانبية أحياناً يُعرّف الناس الإخلاص على أنه
مربع الدالة التي عرّفتها هنا ويسمون هذه الدالة جذر
الإخلاص. سترون التعريف بكلتا الطريقتين وهذا بالتأكيد قد يسبب ارتباكاً لكنه عادةً لا يحدث
لأن الناس عموماً حريصون على توضيح أي تعريف يستخدمون. ويجب أن
تفعل نفس الشيء. في رأيي لا يوجد حقاً تعريف صحيح أو خاطئ. أنا أعرّفه
هكذا ببساطة لأنني اعتدت على فعل ذلك بهذه الطريقة. وأجد أنه أكثر ملاءمة قليلاً لأنني أفضل أن أربّع
شيئاً بدلاً من أخذ جذر تربيعي لاحقاً عند الحاجة. لكن بالطبع أنتم أحرار في اختياركم.
على كل حال دعوني أعود إلى الإخلاص كما هو معرّف هنا. هناك طرق مكافئة أخرى
لتعريف الإخلاص وهي في الحقيقة دالة رائعة جداً في هذا الصدد ويمكن توصيفها ببعض الطرق المثيرة
للاهتمام. هنا طريقة بسيطة لإعادة كتابة التعريف بدلالة نظيم الأثر الذي رأيناه قرب
نهاية الدرس السابق. لم أدخل في تفاصيل كثيرة عن نظيم الأثر وبشكل خاص لم
أعرّفه حتى للمصفوفات غير الهرمتية. لكن تعريفه بسيط بما يكفي: إحدى طرق تعريف نظيم الأثر لمصفوفة
عشوائية M هي أنه أثر الجذر التربيعي لـ M ضرب M المرافقة أو ما يكافئ أثر الجذر
التربيعي لـ M المرافقة ضرب M. تحصل على نفس القيمة بأي من الطريقتين. ويمكننا استخدام هذا التعريف لتبسيط
تعريف الإخلاص كما لدينا هنا أسفل الشاشة. وهذا جميل لأنه يكشف أن
الدالة متماثلة في المتغيرين. يمكننا أيضاً التعبير عن نظيم الأثر لمصفوفة مربعة M على أنه
أقصى قيمة مطلقة لأثر M ضرب U على جميع المصفوفات الوحدوية U وهذا ليس واضحاً لكنه
صحيح. وذلك يعطينا تعبيراً آخر للإخلاص. فلدينا هنا ثلاثة
تعريفات مكافئة للإخلاص وهذه فقط البداية. هناك عدة تعريفات مكافئة أخرى
وسنرى تعريفاً مهماً بشكل خاص يأتي من نظرية Uhlmann قرب نهاية الدرس.
حسناً هذا جيد لكن ماذا يعني كل هذا على المستوى الحدسي ولماذا يجب أن نهتم بهذه
الدالة؟ للإجابة على هذه الأسئلة من المفيد النظر في الحالة الخاصة التي تكون فيها واحدة على الأقل من مصفوفتي
الكثافة تمثل حالة نقية. إذا كانت كلتا الحالتين نقيتين فإن
الإخلاص هو ببساطة القيمة المطلقة للجداء الداخلي بين متجهي الحالة الكمية. وبطرق عديدة
يُعد هذا دافعاً أساسياً للإخلاص نفسه. القيمة المطلقة للجداء الداخلي بين متجهي حالة
كمية هي دائماً عدد بين صفر وواحد وتعطينا طريقة طبيعية لقياس مقدار التداخل
بين متجهي حالة كمية. ويمكنك التفكير في الإخلاص كطريقة مفيدة وحسنة السلوك
لتوسيع طريقة قياس التداخل هذه من الحالات النقية إلى مصفوفات الكثافة. إذا كانت إحدى الحالتين نقية
والأخرى ليست بالضرورة نقية فلدينا مرة أخرى تعبير بسيط للإخلاص يمكن أن يكون
مفيداً جداً وهو موضح هنا. للإخلاص خصائص مثيرة
كثيرة وهذا أحد أسباب استخدام الناس له. تعريفه ليس الأجمل
حقاً لكنه دالة مفيدة جداً مع ذلك. وغالباً ما يكون سهل الاستخدام جزئياً بسبب خصائصه الرائعة
الكثيرة. فلنلقِ نظرة على بعضها بدءاً من ملاحظة أن الإخلاص بين مصفوفتي
كثافة هو دائماً عدد بين 0 وواحد. يكون صفراً إذا وفقط إذا كانت الحالتان
متعامدتين بمعنى أن صورتيهما فضاءان جزئيان متعامدان أو ما يكافئ أن جداء المصفوفتين
يساوي صفراً. ويكون الإخلاص واحداً إذا وفقط إذا كانت مصفوفتا الكثافة متساويتين. كل حالة أخرى تقع بينهما
لكن حدسياً كلما اقترب الإخلاص من واحد كلما كانت الحالتان أكثر تشابهاً أو بديلاً
أكثر تداخلاً. الإخلاص أيضاً متماثل وقد ذكرت ذلك قبل لحظات.
هذا واضح جداً من التعبير الذي رأيناه للإخلاص بدلالة نظيم الأثر لكنه شيء مهم يجب إدراكه
مع ذلك. بعد ذلك الإخلاص ضربي لحالات الجداء التنسوري بمعنى أن الإخلاص بين
حالتي جداء تنسوري يساوي دائماً جداء الإخلاص بين الحالات
الفردية. هنا خاصية مفيدة جداً: إذا كان لدينا أي مصفوفتي كثافة من نفس الحجم
مع أي قناة تأخذ هاتين المصفوفتين كمدخلات فإن الإخلاص لا يمكن إلا أن يكبر عند تطبيق تلك القناة
على كلتا الحالتين. بعبارة أخرى من حيث الإخلاص القنوات لا يمكنها إلا أن تجعل الحالات
أكثر تشابهاً. لا يمكنها جعلها أقل تشابهاً. وأخيراً لهذه القائمة على الأقل
هناك علاقة وثيقة جداً بين الإخلاص ومسافة الأثر بين الحالات والتي تُعرّف
بنصف نظيم الأثر للفرق بين مصفوفتي الكثافة. مسافة الأثر بين
حالتين ترتبط بقوة بمدى قدرتنا على التمييز بينهما والذي ناقشناه في الدرس السابق في سياق
تمييز الحالات ونظرية Helstrom-Holevo. بينما الإخلاص يقيس مقدار تداخل
حالتين. فرغم أنهما ليسا نفس الشيء تماماً ليس من المفاجئ أن هناك علاقة بين هذين
المقدارين. وعلى كل حال هذه المتباينات التي تُسمى عادةً متباينات Fuchs-van de Graaf تجعل
هذه العلاقة دقيقة رياضياً. والمهم جداً أنه لا يوجد أي اعتماد هنا على حجم النظام الذي نتحدث
عنه. يمكننا رؤية هذه العلاقة بوضوح أكبر بمساعدة شكل. إذا كان لدينا حالتان و
حددنا مسافة الأثر بينهما على المحور الأفقي والإخلاص على المحور الرأسي فإن الخطين الرأسي
والأفقي المقابلين يجب أن يتقاطعا في مكان ما داخل هذه المنطقة الرمادية. أكثر منطقة مثيرة للاهتمام
في الرسم بالمناسبة على الأقل من الناحية العملية هي الزاوية العلوية اليسرى من المنطقة الرمادية. بشكل خاص عندما تكون
مسافة الأثر صغيرة جداً فلا بد أن يكون الإخلاص قريباً جداً من واحد والعكس
صحيح. هذه المتباينات تُستخدم بشكل متكرر جداً وجزء من السبب هو أننا غالباً ما نهتم أكثر
بمسافة الأثر في النهاية لأن لها تفسيراً طبيعياً يرتبط بتمييز الحالة الكمية.
لكن الإخلاص يملك خصائص رائعة كثيرة تجعله عموماً الأسهل للعمل معه. وطالما نحن في الزاوية العلوية اليسرى من
المنطقة الرمادية وهو غالباً ما نكون لا نخسر كثيراً بالتحويل بين الإخلاص ومسافة الأثر. فهذه
بعض خصائص الإخلاص. هناك المزيد لكنها بداية جيدة وآمل أن القائمة
مفيدة لبدء تطوير حدس عن الإخلاص. هنا مثال جميل على كيفية
ربط الإخلاص بالقياسات غير المدمرة. إنها حقيقة مفيدة جداً تُعرف بمبرهنة القياس
اللطيف. لنفترض أن لدينا نظاماً X وحالة لـ X ممثلة بمصفوفة كثافة rho وقياساً على النظام X
موصوفاً بمجموعة من المصفوفات شبه الموجبة المحددة. لنفترض أن إحدى نتائج القياس من المرجح جداً أن
تظهر إذا أجرينا القياس على الحالة rho. للبساطة لنفترض
أنها النتيجة صفر التي من المرجح جداً ظهورها. وبشكل خاص لنفترض أن هذه النتيجة تظهر باحتمال
أكبر من واحد ناقص epsilon لقيمة صغيرة ما من epsilon لا نحتاج فعلاً تحديدها. epsilon
هو مجرد عدد حقيقي موجب صغير. الآن وصفنا قياسنا كما لو كان قياساً
مدمراً لكننا نعلم من الدرس السابق أنه يمكننا تنفيذ هذا القياس بطريقة غير مدمرة. وتحديداً يمكننا ذلك كما
رأينا في مناقشتنا لنظرية Naimark. ويعمل هكذا: كل نتيجة a تظهر
باحتمال يساوي أثر PA ضرب rho وبشرط الحصول على تلك النتيجة تتغير حالة X بشكل
خاص في حالة حصولنا على النتيجة المرجحة صفر تصبح الحالة الجذر التربيعي لـ P0 ضرب rho ضرب الجذر التربيعي لـ P0
كل ذلك منظم لنحصل على مصفوفة كثافة. وما تخبرنا به مبرهنة القياس اللطيف هو أنه في هذه الحالة
بمعنى أننا فعلاً حصلنا على نتيجة القياس المرجحة فإن الحالة التي نحصل عليها لن تكون قد تغيرت كثيراً عن
الأصلية. وبشكل خاص مربع الإخلاص سيكون بالضرورة أكبر من واحد ناقص
epsilon. وهذا رائع لأنه عام تماماً. لم نقل شيئاً على الإطلاق عن القياس أو
الحالة سوى أن إحدى النتائج مرجحة جداً. فالمبرهنة يمكن تطبيقها في
سياقات كثيرة مختلفة حيث نريد التحقق من شيء عن حالة كمية بدون إزعاجها كثيراً. فلنرَ كيف يمكننا
إثباتها. وفي معظم الأمر هو حساب بسيط للإخلاص بين حالتي ما قبل وما بعد
القياس. يمكننا فعل ذلك باستخدام التعريف الأصلي وعادةً قد يتركنا ذلك مع صيغة فوضوية لكن
في هذه الحالة يحالفنا الحظ لأن الشيء داخل الجذر التربيعي الخارجي هو في الحقيقة مربع مصفوفة
تكون شبه موجبة المحددة مما يجعل حساب الجذر التربيعي بسيطاً جداً. يمكننا الآن استخدام الخاصية الدورية
للأثر مع خطية الأثر لتبسيط تعبيرنا كما هو موضح على الشاشة. لاحظ بالمناسبة أن هذه
كلها مساواة فلم نقرّب شيئاً حتى الآن. نحن فقط نبسّط. لكن الآن نحتاج
متباينة لأننا نريد التخلص من ذلك الجذر التربيعي في البسط. ويمكننا فعل ذلك فعلاً إذا قبلنا بحد أدنى. وإذا
كنت مهتماً بالتفاصيل لهذا الجزء يمكنك الحصول على المتباينة بسهولة بالنظر في تحليل طيفي لـ P
0. القيم الذاتية لـ P0 يجب أن تكون بين 0 وواحد وهذا صحيح دائماً للمصفوفات التي تصف
قياسات. وبمجرد معرفة ذلك تنتج المتباينة مباشرة من حقيقة أن أخذ الجذر التربيعي
لعدد بين 0 وواحد لا يمكن إلا أن يجعله أكبر. طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي أن تربيع عدد بين 0 و
واحد لا يمكن إلا أن يجعله أصغر. يمكننا الآن التبسيط قليلاً أكثر ونحصل على الجذر
التربيعي لأثر P0 ضرب rho. وأخيراً بتربيع الطرفين
وتعويض حدنا على الاحتمال نحصل على ما نريد. فصيغة الإخلاص
ليست الأجمل أو الأسهل استخداماً في العالم لكنها هنا تعمل بشكل
جيد جداً. لنختم الدرس سنلقي نظرة على نظرية Uhlmann وهي حقيقة أساسية عن الإخلاص
تربطه بمفهوم التنقية. ما تقوله النظرية ببساطة هو أن الإخلاص بين أي حالتين
كميتين يساوي أقصى جداء داخلي بالقيمة المطلقة بين تنقيتين لهاتين
الحالتين. بمزيد من التفصيل لنفترض أن rho و sigma مصفوفتا كثافة لنظام X ما ولنفترض أن Y
نظام لديه على الأقل نفس عدد الحالات الكلاسيكية التي لدى X وبالتالي نضمن أن كلتا الحالتين لها تنقيات هي
متجهات حالة كمية لـ XY. يمكننا عندئذ التعبير عن مضمون النظرية بالمعادلة
الموضحة على الشاشة. الإخلاص بين rho و sigma يساوي أقصى قيمة مطلقة للجداء الداخلي
بين phi و psi على جميع phi و psi التي تنقي rho و sigma
على التوالي. فلنرتب هذا ونعمل مع العبارة الرياضية الدقيقة. ما سنفعله الآن هو إثبات
النظرية. لكن أولاً يستحق التوقف لحظة لتقدير أنها تقدم لنا طريقة حدسية جداً للتفكير في
الإخلاص. وهي أيضاً مفيدة جداً بحد ذاتها. مثلاً لإثبات أشياء أكثر إثارة عن
الإخلاص. لإثباتها سنبدأ بتحليلات طيفية لمصفوفتي
الكثافة. لا مفاجآت هناك. بمجرد أن لدينا تحليلات طيفية من السهل إيجاد
تنقيتين محددتين لهاتين الحالتين. لكن هنا سنستخدم
حيلة. لاحظ أنه في كلتا الحالتين لا نستخدم متجه أساس معياري كعامل تنسوري ثانٍ كما فعلنا سابقاً في
الدرس. بل لدينا نفس المتجه كما في العامل التنسوري الأول لكن عليه شريط و
هذا يعني المرافق المركب لعناصر هذه المتجهات. بعبارة أخرى نحن أساساً نأخذ
نسخة ثانية من المتجهات الذاتية لكن نأخذ المرافق المركب لكل عنصر. وسنرى لماذا نفعل ذلك بعد لحظات
قليلة. لكن ليس واضحاً أبداً أنه يجب علينا فعل ذلك ولهذا نسميه
حيلة. في كل الأحوال هذه تنقيات لـ rho و sigma على التوالي وذلك صحيح بحكم
كون متجهاتنا الذاتية متعامدة معيارية وبالتالي مرافقاتها المركبة كذلك. والآن يمكننا تطبيق
التكافؤ الوحدوي للتنقيات الذي يقول أن كل تنقية لحالتينا يمكن الحصول عليها بتطبيق
عملية وحدوية على النظام الذي يُؤخذ أثره الجزئي. للتنقيات المحددة التي
اخترناها للتو لا يلزم أن تكون العمليتان الوحدويتان نفسهما للتنقيتين
بالطبع. فهنا نستخدم الحرف U للأولى والحرف V للثانية.
فالنقطة هي أن كل تنقية لحالتينا يمكن كتابتها كما لدينا على الشاشة
لاختيار ما من العمليات الوحدوية U و V. والآن يمكننا أخذ التعبير
من النظرية وتبسيطه. إذا عوّضنا تعبيرينا عن phi و psi وبسّطنا قليلاً
نحصل على التعبير الموضح هنا على الشاشة. هناك خطوتان في ذلك ولم أُظهر التفاصيل
فأنتم تعرفون ما يجب فعله إذا أردتم ذلك. لكن دعوني أذكر أن سبب اختيارنا للتنقيات كما فعلنا
هو للسماح لهذا الجداء الداخلي بالتبسيط بهذا الشكل تحديداً. وبالذات وضعنا المرافقات المركبة
هناك حتى نتمكن فعلياً من عكس الجداءات الداخلية في العامل التنسوري الثاني للحصول على الشكل
المحدد الذي لدينا هنا. نحن قريبون جداً الآن. يمكننا استخدام الخاصية الدورية للأثر مع
التحليلات الطيفية التي بدأنا بها للحصول على هذا التعبير. وعند هذه النقطة يمكننا
استخدام إحدى الطرق البديلة للتعبير عن الإخلاص باستخدام نظيم الأثر و
ننتهي. بالتأكيد هناك تفاصيل مررت عليها بسرعة كبيرة وهو نوع البرهان الذي
تحتاج فعلاً للعمل عليه بنفسك لتستوعبه تماماً. لكن آمل أن هذا يعطيكم الفكرة
الأساسية. وكالعادة يمكنكم إيجاد مزيد من التفاصيل في المحتوى المكتوب للدرس المرتبط في وصف
الفيديو. وهذه نهاية الدرس الذي كان عن التنقيات والإخلاص والروابط بينهما وهو أيضاً
نهاية الوحدة التي كانت عن الصياغة العامة للمعلومات الكمية. أتمنى أن تنضموا إليّ في
الوحدة الرابعة والأخيرة من السلسلة التي تتناول تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية. شكراً على المشاهدة.